with almost 500 sessions at next 2019
it's understandable that you can get to
the mall so if you didn't see how AI is
transforming the enterprise then stay
tuned because here's the rewind ai is no
longer science fiction it's here and
it's up to you to be creative with it
but what does that look like in practice
and how do you actually use it to
transform your industry at scale if you
want to take a peek behind that curtain
and find out how familiar enterprises
adopt AI with game-changing results then
this talk is for you it brings you cloud
customers stories of frustrations and
triumph stories that are deep practical
inspiring and very real
you'll meet Fox Sports an Australian
media and entertainment company that
uses AI to transform sports by alerting
fans when something exciting is about to
happen
join Hulu for a behind-the-scenes look
at data quality and see how AI can be
used to generate better data for other
AI applications while bringing more joy
to the work of their customer service
agents now that's creativity going meta
once you've got your creative vision and
your data what's next you're gonna need
a model the model is just a fancy word
for recipe now traditional AI was all
about making every recipe yourself but
what is the model that you need already
exists why are we invent the concept of
pizza when you can use your favorite
chef's pizza recipe well it turns out
that's exactly what Google clouds
machine-learning api's are all about
they are recipes that we have made for
you so you can just get cooking we've
done the machine learning heavy lifting
now you can just plug and play though
machine learning API guys make it easy
you can use them to achieve incredibly
visionary things you will be blown away
and inspired to hear about Unilever's
journey with our api's and you might
just raise an eyebrow at their stunning
ROI barring existing solutions is great
but some industries are all about
creating proprietary recipes from
scratch finance is a great example
you'll hear the world's largest asset
manager Blackrock dive into how it uses
AI to stay on top of its game and
navigate its challenges
including the crucial need for
transparency the dangers of unjustified
complexity and new directions for their
future like natural language processing
scale is in Google's DNA and it's
extremely important to the customers you
owe me in this talk so scaling up is a
huge theme but running a global scale
doesn't mean one size has to fit all
Disney's story is all about
personalization they were one of the
first customers to try recommendations
before its public release at Google next
now less than a year later they are
successfully serving a magical
personalized experience for users on
their shop Disney site you'll hear
insights into their testing practices
the power of anonymized data and why we
know that your sleep masks really don't
go with Darth Vader if you'd like to see
the full talk check out the link in the
description below and don't forget to
subscribe to the cloud YouTube channel
for more great next rewind content
thanks for watching
[Music]